I am 25 pounds heavier than I was on the
cover of a very famous swimsuit magazine
that came out last year yeah that
magazine that Sports Illustrated and
Tyra Banks is opening up about how her
body has changed since she slayed on the
cover last year I never got to be
possible in 45 years or older covering
this magazine the 46 year old supermodel
sat down with Harper's Bazaar and listed
out all the things she eats in a day and
it is goals do I want corn chip or do I
want Sesame Bar which sounds weird but
it is so good or do I want some kind of
like natural licorice or do I want some
bean dip or do I want some like
cauliflower puffs and sometimes I want
every single one of those listening to
Tyra wax on about a bagel is beautiful
and poetic and it's making me freakin
hungry but let me tell you how I do my
bagels I take my whipped cream cheese
and I dig deep into that pot of it and I
feel up the entire scooped out bagel
rounds like a moat but I'm not finished
yet
then I take that plate of that moated
cream cheese bagel and I put it inside
of the microwave oh my god I'm drooling
I have a very interesting relationship
with food I have to say that it is one
of the most important things in my life
same girl same right now you can't tell
because I have on a men's blazer I am 25
pounds heavier then I was on the cover
of a very famous swimsuit magazine that
came out last year yep Tyra is talking
about this cover where she dropped jaws
rocking and Eddie
the yellow bikini and Tyra being the
confident queen that she is says she has
no issue with her weight gain and she
just wants to eat what she likes she
even says she likes to order in the same
meal from two different restaurants to
compare I do it with my son I do it with
my man we line it up and then we score
the different restaurants with the same
items and what happens is the next time
you order you'll know where to order
from because one of them is always nasty
that game is inspired and I'm doing it
like right now two orders of nachos
coming right up anyway et said I'm with
Tyra last year to talk about that Sports
Illustrated cover and she said she was
about 25 to 30 pounds heavier than when
she appeared on the mag's cover in 1997
and Tyra was a okay with that I'm in a
new face you know I have a new body I I
will be honest I do know how to lose
weight I know what to eat I have one of
the best nutritionist in the world and
when I was like okay I'm gonna shoot si
again I was like okay I'm gonna pull it
together I'm gonna get my body the same
exact size from 22 years ago and I
started and I was so focused and then I
went to my mom's house and there were
some Cheetos in the in the and I just
had the Cheetos and then that was like
the gateway in and then I was like after
Cheetos you have to have an ice-cream
party I think I was like you know what
let me just celebrate what I am now and
just be real because I'm constantly
telling people beauty and all sizes
beauty and all ages but I look like my
old self right so I think subconsciously
was like nah let's kind of show him
what's up now and she said she was ready
to take on the haters you know the
internet particularly social media is
the most beautiful thing in the world
and the meanest thing in the world and
so I know there's gonna be people
putting pictures next to each other
going oh she's thicker now or she's this
she's that or sit your old ass down I
know that's gonna happen but I didn't do
this for them actually
mMmmm I did do it for them please do
because the people that are saying that
actually have a negativity associated
with themselves with body with age the
person that is telling somebody is such
a old ass down was terrified of Aging
yes it's actually of course Tyra hasn't
shied away from shutting down the
critics who have come at her for her
weight in 2007 Tyra famously told the
trolls to take a hike on the Tyra Banks
Show I have one thing to say to you kiss
my fat and in 2018 she opened up to et
about that moment and admitted she
almost asked her producers to redo it I
felt like I had a responsibility you
know I wasn't just thinking ratings I
was thinking I have a responsibility to
be strong be noble and to say kiss my
fat like this yeah and I thought any
emotion any breaking any tears was weak
and that I had all these women I felt on
my shoulders and I needed to support
them
[Music]